Hey look at the niggers in this country
what do they want they want people to
come from Africa dimensionhole people
they stick up for their own kind the
maximum or Mexicans here it's that way
we're at mother Emanuel Church the
strategies on the country talking about
racism especially in the south so we're
going to take a road trip to where Dylan
roof grew up along the way we're going
to stop and ask folks is the South more
racist have you experienced any racism
here as an african-american woman no did
you grow up in the south
I grew up in the South I see a lot of
thing I think like like we are really
learning like I didn't like people give
whenever curl the skin like I hate maybe
it's the need to cause everybody to act
the way they do recently President Obama
said that we need to start getting real
about racism and stop stop being so
polite what do you think he needs to be
a president and lead this country
and not get involved in these types
we made it to the Statehouse in the
capital Columbia where the Confederate
flag is flying and debates are raging so
let's go talk to some folks is the South
more racist - races No if you ask most
white people how often do you think
about race they would say I don't write
so if you ask black people - do you
think about race I think most was a
everyday there's all black colleges
there's all black churches nobody
complains but if whites have all black
coffee all white college all white
church they're races I think it comes
from a history of the fact that they had
to because of segregation they had to
establish their own schools and churches
yeah African American and if I go along
good back then I said I got into the
segregation everybody got along good so
we've reached Lexington this is where
Dylan roof actually went to high school
and we're gonna see who we can talk to
around here is there a problem with
racism out here of course it is so
down here
what went on in your mind when you heard
about what Dylan oh I wasn't surprised
why we always knew the kid was messed up
and we knew he was going to do something
like that but we never thought he would
actually do it like that
is there a lot of racism in Lexington
South Carolina how it is a good old boy
state to classify it a lot of riots are
starting because of racism Charleston is
actually there they're answering it with
class we are not automatic going to wake
up one day and being a post-racial
society unless we work to that end I
think everybody wants to be kind
everyone wants to be nice but underneath
that the waters run very deep okay just
to give you a flavor of the different
type of Confederate gear they have here
in the store this is a flag for $5 this
is a cutting board about $17